it has the glossy top and it's quite
like flat and a good size
what are you talking about so we're in
Germany doing yeah and we are going to
try some McDonald's here and see how it
is different from the American McDonald
so the places you don't really have them
that much compared to America McDonald's
Burger King all the place to go to the
burger recently we got more and more
burgers are not mean yeah we love
sausage bread sausage in Brandon this is
a signature collection Asik chicken this
looks like really fancy a lot of stuff
on there onions chicken bacon
oh wow it's really good a chicken is
good pull it very thick mustard on top
and ketchup on the bottom so folks also
go really low and if it's like the
classic one so there's nothing really
more added other than the bacon
[Music]
Signature Collection again but beef
special which has bacon and egg so it's
not classic it's special I'm expecting
look normal
me too I know the chicken was so good
it's already falling I'm really
interested in the egg I like the taste
actually even worn in the tree you like
it I mean I'm more like a beef type
anyway here a piece time yeah oh wow
it's a huge burger that's really big
it's just like a normal big burger I see
barbecue sauce a sea of white stuff
nothing special nothing German about
them no these are happy fries a little
bit like you oh it's very bready I mean
I know a lot of people like crispy but I
like this there's like actually
different faces and it makes me have to
give a little bad weather here recently
so maybe that's why they have the
slightly pieces of ice and happy chicken
box chicken nuggets and some chicken
wings so we're gonna eat with that sweet
and sour sauce shoots a lot suicide I
guess if you're really craving chicken
huh you can go get my chicken Bob fat
you know what they should do they should
do the chicken box also with the chicken
burger it so it's like triple chicken
okay thanks for reacting - uh-huh
so we got some that Clarie I always get
Oreo in America so we try to get some
different flavors mine is the caramel
one - called small teens it's not to
shut that sorry mmm spacing not McFlurry
oh okay that's like little chocolates
all of your favorite oh I like the
chicken in the story
I like the classic chicken burger
signing off from Germany sanction I fish
in thank you should I'm meeting all the
rest all the leftovers that's fine
[Music]